peu
et maintenant joueront alors je vous
rappelle que le kaléidoscope et à 500
francs et vous faites un jeu complet oui
mais vous savez comment comment voulez
vous une note
notre mieux mais bon ce n'est pas non
mais ce mardi sous la dent contre
acheter mais parce que là c'est que vous
êtes en plein là je sais pas si vous
avez vu mes choix
vous le voyez les nus à huîtres est tout
à fait bien sinon on va courir comme ça
et là maintenant il faut que vous êtes
touché la côte mais bien mais je fais
que ça vient non bien que j'ai fait est
là mais bien mais je touche
ouais bon des contrats mais comprend pas
le français touchent la touche
nous avons bien je vous remercie
beaucoup mieux mais la prochaine fois
j'espère que je comprendrais que la fête
est finie ou à 3 minutes que je fais que
tous âges avait pas grand bruit vous
égare touchés bon on continue madame
alice la rue alice bonjour alors je vois
à mon avis car ces morts qui arrive une
fois de plus mieux jouer encore un bon
petit tour je vous demande d'attendre
quelques secondes alissa goodman roule
pas à vous de la musique tout semry une
balle file à but non mais là c'est tout
ça alors la petite balle à la main
droite
non la droite mais la droite un de nos
sessions dont on craint beaucoup pour
moi c'était le goût voilà ménagé par une
autre belle régate bien là le pouce il
est fait comme ça
oddo
doucement doucement les deux balles sont
là mais c'est pas ça ce qu'ils voulaient
faire parce que mes nerfs faire entrer
cette base la suite beauté 5,5 bavarois
oui mais tous y reconnaître une pièce de
5 francs la bouteille et aériennes du
nord n'ont rien fait rentrer la pièce de
danse regarde bien le voilà alors ça
franchement ça fait tu l'as fait sur tes
cheveux
ah oui bravo garcimore vraiment bravo
nous ne s'appliquerait quand même tout à
l'heure que j'arrive à comprendre
quelque chose comme au moins un tour
dans cette émission
bonjour l'été ou la retrouverai
maintenant vers 16h45 pour notre
troisième et avant dernier jeu est pour
le moment et bien je vous laisse en
compagnie de pierre douglas a tout à
l'air ça me manquait un petit célèbre
chinois les coins j'appelle les bambous
sinon les baguettes chinoises
c'est un tout très essentielle des nazis
alors que les japonais fabriquent tous
les objectifs du chanvre et vous pensez
que moi je te dis comprendre japonais
j'étais déçu ils s'élèvent tout ça c'est
pas au nom même si je suis touche pas
mais j'ai le fil en face à me paraît
quand même assez facile non bah oui en
bas c'est normal
le ris s'installe chez compris nombreux
[Rires]
public ils voient pas les petits fish
and will fall a quand même honnêtement
on est tous maintenant il n'y a pas de
pluie parce que comment j'ai coupé
oui si ça marche on va tirer comme ça ça
ne marche pas mal pourquoi moi je te pas
le flair alors attendez j'ai cru
comprendre mais je serais incapable de
vous l'expliquer ce qui fait quand même
plus qu il a sûrement qu'un truc et des
contrats de 2 mètres le cul bon eh ben
je vous remercie beaucoup avaient quand
même m'expliquer ça après alors voilà on
vous laisse en compagnie de pierre
douglas
[Musique]
alors vous avez le choix
les deux copains qui n'a vraiment pas
alors plongée ou saab est une terreur
oui de 10
un premier concurrent et bien ce sera
trouville madame raymonde das ville
raymonde bonjour quel est votre soirée
monde 3500 francs raymond a quoi pensez
vous je pense à la présentation de
[Rires]
madame parfaite comme ça madame marie
qu'un outil qui habite ajaccio en corse
marie bonjour oui pardon un baldaquin
non ce n'est pas un baldaquin marine
béthune dans le pas-de-calais madame
claudie boulanger claudie bonjour que
c'est pour la communication
je me permets de vous dire que vous êtes
encore plus votre bonheur
mais vous avez aimé mais ils font
n'importe quoi
en tout cas je vous remercie beaucoup
madame que choisissez vous oui alors
j'ai pensé à tous averse était pas pour
toujours je l'a évidemment vous à écrire
un jeu partout au pij ou de la couronne
de toccata première non non madame ce
n'est pas ça mais monsieur maxime fois
de poitiers
maxime bonjour quand avez vous choisi
maxime pardon oui ça n'est pas ça nico
choisissez bull a maintenant très bien
alors le kaléidoscope est à treize mille
cinq cents francs
pardon merci parce qu'il est célibataire
madame marie claire des veaux qui habite
bonnet dans la saône et loire
marie-claire bonjour bonjour le mieux
votre choix marie claire marie claude
non marie-claude ça n'est pas un tissu
de cachemire merci monsieur stéphane
ados stéphane bonjour qu avez-vous
choisi cet effet un caméscope annoncé
c'est un ensemble des plus d'oiseaux qui
servait aux indiens comme chapeaux sont
démunis plume qui servait attendu puis
me répéter oui c'est un ensemble des
plis faisait oiseau qui servait aux
inquiets comme chapeau non c'est pas ça
c'est pas ça s'est passé stephen madame
yvonne pas exempt ils veulent bonjour
bonjour d'ennemis alors oui le
kaléidoscope oui alors j'ai pensé à
tenir car goerig ensuite la nourrice à
mes pattes à madame suzanne opep à venir
à l'eau qui êtes vous un capitaine
bonjour madame vous choisissez vous le
kaléidoscope
alors il est à 13 milles 5 alors je
pense à un costume à marcq
exactement non ce n'est pas non plus un
masque d'esquimaux merci beaucoup
madame monsieur georges trans il est
bonjour monsieur bonjour baisse continue
pardon madame j'ai choisi le cas les
deux records oui je pense à la carte que
portait le coin charmant nos jours
non ce n'est pas ça merci beaucoup mais
ça ne passe à madame danielle guillais
daniel bonjour qu avez-vous choisi oui
alors je pensais aller mourey qui se
trouve à l'intérieur de l'église miniato
allemands n'ont pas les bassins l'umq
monsieur didier là qu'est didier bonjour
bonjour denis pendant tout ce temps elle
est montée à 2100 francs cette énigme
voulez vous que je vous rappelle la
question didier les frontières
naturelles de cette île mystérieuse ont
été empruntés à quatre pays différents
quelles sont ces pays c'est ce que j'ai
dit on plaît ou pas vous choisissez
l'énigme ou le kaléidoscope oui bon on à
numéroter les les pays
alors à quoi pensez-vous monsieur non
papillon non ça n'est pas ça
madame brigitte dupont
brigitte bonjour vous plaît oui et ce
que je porte à une une couronne de quoi
nous ce n'est pas une couronne de compte
mon aventure
madame bonaventure belle aventure pour
allô allô
comment vous appelez-vous monsieur chez
moi la voiture
oh la la
que choisissez vous monsieur je vous
rappelle la question des frontières
naturelles de cette île mystérieuse a
été emprunté à quatre pays différents
quelles sont ces pays il ya quatre pays
monsieur non ça fait 5 mais de toute
façon ça n'est pas ça monsieur
merci beaucoup j'ai le un concurrent
encore gérard et bien c'est monsieur
jean marc manach célian fini non banon
madina vincent petit tout ce qu'ils
fassent ce qu'il faut en phase donc
alors non excusez-moi mais je nous
n'avons plus le temps alors en tout cas
pour jouer avec nous il faut nous écrire
sur cartes postales votre nom votre
numéro téléphone et l'indicatif de votre
département et il n'est nous envoyer
cette carte postale à et maintenant
jument cedex 15 175 300 paris bruit
voilà eh bien c'était notre dernier jeu
de l'après midi oui mais en tout cas moi
je remercie dieu je remercie je vous
remercie tous les deux d'avoir autant et
des non je vous en prie ne meure va
rester modeste garcimore a beaucoup ri
parce qu'il comprend toujours pas ce qui
se passe
j'en ai parlé de ma vie mais ne comprend
pas le kaléidoscope pour lui c'est une
énigme et vice et versa alors alors des
avancées des risques concernant les
temps de me revoir les catins alors on
va sur ses tracas tout à fait à dessein
par exemple 2 il devra pas prendre ça
soit là parce qu'elle n'a pas beaucoup
de temps très bien vous allez voir le
tract ils vont sortez d'où sort du jury
ça vous rappelle quelque chose özil
avait déjà fait mais qui a reçu beaucoup
de lettres des enfants qui voulaient le
voir ce qu'ils disaient qu'ils étaient
nuls et 4 dans la main qu'ils s'étaient
trompés type qui voyait pas bien alors
je vais le faire une nouvelle fois et a
payé ou s'expliquer le tricot mais au
fait oui fait comme ça à 50 ans c'est
long c'est vite fait pas comme ça y est
tous pas regarder un souffle il est
créatif ils sortent tous envoyés alors
sa masse pas ah oui ça marche et ça
coupe tout seul voilà les trois quarts
qui sont sortis il y en a ne naîtra
alors exceptionnellement puisque mike
williams et l'étude mesure la
cession-bail et/ou s'expliquer le truc
spécial c'est très facile c'est pas moi
qui fais les tricks regarde bien c'est
pas moi qui le fais ça vous intéresser
les revendre et acquitte attaque il faut
le tout c'est pas moi oui si vous
acceptez marc simon charmant vous dis
non merci non non son dessin qui ne
réagissent pas non me coûtait encore qui
souffrent bien quoi merci mon cher josé
tous nos compliments cher denis vous
avez fait gagner aujourd'hui un
téléspectateur
et puis vous avez gardez votre sang
froid si j'ose m'exprimer racing grâce à
un but de gyan prestigieuse est terminée
elle recommencera samedi prochain à la
même heure c'est tout va bien vers 14h05
14h08 bon week-end sur tf1 au revoir
[Musique]
voilà maintenant c'est à vous de jouer
je vous rappelle que le kaléidoscope et
à 9800 pro et l'énigme à 7400 francs je
crois que nous pouvons tout de suite
commencer gérard le bailli de
saint-egrève dans l'isère bonjour
garcimore barclays voulait pas et la jmj
un petit tour ici oui oui mais moi je
veux bien mais j'ai deux fils elle vous
pouvez les regarder
je voulais alors la garderie de fils il
ya un petit nu
oui on l'a alors s'il vous plaît vous
allez à souffler sophie plus fort bravo
que c'est vraiment me réserver la
primeur un des fondements
non mais encore il est tellement cool
oui j'ai quelques cartes ici j'en avais
je vous ai vue de faire de loin tout à
l'heure mais jusqu'à demander de les
répéter
alors on a 1 2 3 4 5 4 mais celle là qui
a au million seller wadi pic alors j'ai
pris aussi la quête que vous voulez de
celle là oui lesquelles des quatre qui
l'entourent c'est pas le droit de
choisir sa vie puisqu'il est également
parce que ce que je vais vous dire
laquelle du soin ni choisi ça le web des
cadeaux oui mais pourquoi pas comme ça
les gars veulent puisqu'ils bas il mâche
et heureusement on souffle il est 8 des
carreaux que vous avez choisi il est là
simonet
c'est vraiment assez extraordinaire vous
voulez une autre affiche dans tout ça
prend des piques
oui mais pas celle où tu soulèves non
c'est bien moi ça m'est égal 3 d'epic
il est rentré dedans sans décolleté
oui depuis qu'il est là mais comment
vous faites ça vous les pendules
expliqué un jour en direct quand même
parce qu'après vous savez une fois
qu'ils les auront elles n'expliquent en
rien du tout moi je ne sais rien jamais
ne même expliqué le trio vient d'ouvrir
le champ de la les bébés de tak tak
hyper très écouté ça peut attendre c'est
vraiment garcimore voyez vous alors là
je vais vous dire une chose je ne dois
me rien alors pour jouer j'ai plus
corécepteur qu'il ya deux mois non mais
c'est gentil vous l'apprenez elle et ses
enfants et nos petits-enfants et puis
voilà vous pose non franchement écouter
non comment voulez vous être sérieux
tranquille dans ce plateau en bout
on vous met des souris barthes ou non
alors selon sérieux gérard maintenant
commençons à jouer nous avons des sommes
importantes qui sont en jeu
kaléidoscope 9600 francs et l'énigme
7400 français que si j'avais un
récepteur qui marche ce serait
merveilleux à l'aise dans lequel vous
demande un petit moment gérard parce que
j'en ai un qui arrive là j'en ai une
autre sur les genoux
une rustine dans le coeur battre par
pascal honte à qui vous avez fait des
tours alors préparé un petit tour oui et
on a quelqu'un ktla alors vous savez à
chercher de la carte que vous voulez il
avait trouvé la 4g
chaque fois vous vous glissez pour un
tour de karim m'évite de soi l'on
apprenait par contre jamais rien après
le vip non pas seulement l'affairé
regarde ce qu'ils avaient trouvé là
quatre savez je garde rustines
oui vous pouvez pas m'expliquer pourquoi
ses oreilles fond noir il a 2 buts
n'avait bien c'est la carte que vous
avez cherché chez les 2 2 que l'aviation
je vous les connaissez tout parker avait
pas trouvé bon comme on se l'est de
décor qui manquent
je suis actionnaire voilà mais c'est
bien c'est pas pour ça que je suis venu
parce que c'est tout simple ça
m'étonnait aussi je trouve quelque chose
de correct les la capitale soit 6 et les
deux des cas et vous voyez qu'il l'a
cédé 4 oui oui enfin là c'est le dos ils
censurent les cats
alors vous allez bien regarder parce
qu'elle agrafe vous avez se situent les
mains on va essayer que ça allait
tourner tout ça regarde comme ça souffle
plus fort plus fort que ça fait trois
fois que je souffre
et voilà que de dca et chalets tout
comme les décors que vous l'avez soit si
ça allait tourner tout son nom ça c'est
pas mal du tout fois le feu ça fait bref
mais tous pas toujours pas comment ça
marche et vous m'expliquer la colle pas
tout à l'heure si vous voulez bien bien
sûr je m'en vais là on verra merci
garcimore au revoir à bientôt
bonjour garcimore jeu de niche que c'est
gentil de venir me rendre visite
j'avais pas encore d'après midi et oui
non mais je vous vois pas qui a préparé
un petit employé on a une qu'il oui il
l'est une boîte aux parents alors les
l'aider à traverser pour les deux pays
alors aidez vous propose d'essayer de
nouvelles idées mais sans lâcher le bout
de course
c'est à dire que vous savez comme ça
mais ce n'est pas ça oui le dévoué mais
fêter quoi choisi l'énigme que si tous
cas c'est moi j'ai pas très grand mérite
et du pain
je les réponses générales bâti leur faut
alors ils veulent aider mes seins que
vous lassiez les bouts des cours d'eau
at il dit pourrait arriver et je tire
pas moi donc voilà fait encore plus
difficile c'est un petit bout comme ça
ils nous traitent de les attacher les
deux vous que ce sera encore plus
difficile
qu'est ce qu'il va faire dans le vol de
deux il me prépare quelque chose
regardez je veux sortir l'idée de s'en
lasser les bouts de corde on regarde
bien il sait qui sera ce qu'elle est le
plus long que l'autre oui et maintenant
c'est comme ça échange lui paraît tous
deux non mais c'est pas tout à fait
beaucoup pour moi
valverde s'est installé chez le bout de
courant oui mais c'est peut-être parce
que non non non moi je ne pense plus
rien avec vous merci moi vraiment je me
garde bien d'annoncer quoi que ce soit
robin on va souffrir oui je sais pas ce
que vous dites pas de souffle et non
plus le franchement je ressens
maintenant plus fois haut
c'est très joli c'est très très joli
voilà ça c'est votre
ça c'est le petit cadeau de garcimore à
toutes les mamans c'est qu'il a préparé
à l'école cette semaine en classe
bon bah oui il faut que je dise au
revoir à nos amis de strasbourg j'allais
oublier et mais j'espère que vous allez
tout de suite nous rejoindre sur tf1
dans quelques secondes
vous allez retrouver pierre douglas
[Musique]
et maintenant à vous de jouer le
kaléidoscope est à 12800 francs et notre
nouvelle énigme à 500 francs gérard un
premier candidat c'est monsieur joël
moulin de courrières dans le calme mais
parce que j'en ai à nos deux premiers
candidats qui n'était pas prévu au
programme et al adha qui vous n'avez pas
vu alors ok comme la bouche et marié
pasquet peut-être d'agriculteur j'ai un
bébé
oui mais ça va je n'ai alors peut-être
comment tous les mamans pasqualetti côté
pour votre wii et où je fais un cadeau
il y avoue l'aja et chapeaux tricotés
main c'est magique
il me manque les cas si les japonais
mais j'ai compris madame s'écrit aussi
ça veut dire quoi ça alors vas-y
japonaise a dit l'anglais ne savent pas
ce qu'elles valent pas la gueule on va
faire un petit cap tous ça doit vouloir
dire comment tricoter des chaussons
nord-ouest un petit côté des portes à
quoi lui ai dit vous donner un petit le
petit cap tous vous allez tenir comme ça
il va ressortir encore quelque chose
tant que c'est pas de souris ça va oui
et il ya vous apprendre comment il faut
faire voyez vous prenez la pelote de
laine et la pelote de laine écouter les
femmes qui tricotent prennent exemple
sur vous j'ai l'impression que jamais le
finir aux deux raisons mais comme avec
la télé tout ça qu'on n'avait pas le
temps de tricoter ça qui vous ont fait
de lui attribue thème est magique
mais il faut tricoter comme ça des
contrastes et la taille ça s'appelle et
la laine mais comme ça petitement on a
souvent tricoter pour vous montrez nous
comment vous faites une maille à
l'endroit une maille à l'envers le suit
pas la paix maintenant ce que wade est
tricoté enlève c'est pour ça que c'est
magique parce que celle dédiée à
tricoter
[ __ ] vraiment alors franchement y'a
pas à dire on a touché le matériel
n'avait peut-être vocaux et qu'elle
allait mener les débats mais on va
montrer à tout le monde sait déjà et il
n'y a rien du tout les cinématiques pour
votre bébé est allé d'un côté mais de
l'autre
tout ça alors pendant que vous parlez
vous fait de grands gestes pour attirer
votre attention sur un point pendant ce
temps il se passe quelque chose un bon
après midi
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
bon là on voit des pêches c'est avec
monsieur joël moulin à un courriel ou là
bonjour
si vous n'êtes que je crois vous pouvoir
y aller oui denise un premier candidat
tout de suite
excuse moi je ne suis pas là j'épouse à
qui et pour quoi vous répondre mais m'a
placé pour l'emporter automatique qui va
le faire alors des comptes resteront il
est ce votre message une fois que nos
jeunes il est actionnaire et vous avez
l'air sur votre numéro de téléphone
il émule arrivé de vous appeler tout de
suite vous fassiez votre pile avant
terme
franchement ça c'est encore encore qu'à
s'énerve parce qu'en plus de ça vous
avez les moyens d'avoir un répondeur
automatique un retour automatique mais
comme suit troubles éventuels maroc pour
téléphoner là bas une très bonne image
plus mes papiers quand même oui on a
déjà des cas tout à fait normal on est
avec vous tout est normal
à part vous et vous allez associés la
carte que vous voulez la non mais
franchement j'aimerais savoir si je peux
prendre la carte que j'attendais non ces
barrages ou pas c'est pareil sur deux
domaines
franchement écouter garcimore non vous
en profiter parce que pierre n'est pas
là aujourd'hui
les gens te l'envoyer non mais c'est une
blague c'est surtout des félins non ça
c'était la cata luis attaque différente
soit si la 4è voulait d'abord écouté
franchement et je les ai vus tout toutes
les mains alors pourquoi son appareil
vers le sec je voulais lui laisse pas à
peine de leurs cartes et sociaux et
maintenant vous savez a signé à quatre
voyez-vous le citoyen et vos bottines il
regarde tous parce qu'ils doutent une
équipe la nar alors le plateau alors
qu'ils sont tous là avec des airs de
connivence voir ici pas dans le coup oui
montre et il faudra être là signe elle
voudrait signer c'est plus j'ai signé de
bons signes et bien écoutez je ne triche
pas non moi montrèrent la carte avec la
signature
oui oui c'est que non la main droite
voyaient même endroit c'est ça mettez la
main comme ça ou pakistanais il ya là
maintenant je dirais souffrait ilah
khatib a poussé de la ici j'admire la
carte c'était du tf nos taxes vous savez
ce châssis donc cette guitare ou deux et
je ne vois pas pourquoi je vous mettrais
sont l'avant alors vous avez en vrai la
main nous verrons vraiment non mais
c'est pas possible
oui parce qu'il n'est pas là il a
disparu
il a quatre avaient signé des disparus
dans ses portes aux faits auraient le
portefeuille m'attendais a vendu un
portefeuille je voudrais qu'elle caméra
très proche maintenant car simone
enfants ça vaut la peine
non regardez le portefeuille
non regardez le portefeuille non mais
vraiment gênant location voilà alors
maintenant il faut que je donne un
portefeuille alors jetez pas du tout si
le on va partiront pour le monde tout à
l'heure - n'aura pas le temps de faire
jouer qui que ce soit parce que avec
toutes les histoires de portefeuille et
de est levée le plus vite et coûteuse
parce que je peux quand même
il meurt alors je vais vous dire c'est
bien réciproque un non mais ne riez pas
pu trouver un autre système quand même
c'est pas si gentil déjà 4 élastique qui
j'ai pas tout autant de grands noms a
coûté la vie ce qui m'a fait regarder et
là ça va tâcher note que c'est pas
possible
non mais estime non mais c'est pas non
mais franchement comment non non et
comment vous avez fait non non non non
moi je conçois non moi je veux montrer à
la regarder
là c'est là dedans alors je vous
garantis c'est un peu émouvant sur
paroles assez regardé impossible
d'ouvrir moi je comprends plus rien
toute façon ça ne change pas c'est parce
que nous partons pour le monde
directement non on en a le temps de
jouer de faire avec un juge ou à des
choses plus faciles
en fin de compte au moins une concerne
parce qu'au moins là j'ai les réponses
parce que là je n'ai jamais la réponse
de toute façon ça il faut bien se le
dire merci garcimore
je vous rappelle que pour y participer à
ce jeu il vous reste plus donc que
quinze jours très vite vous nous écrivez
sur cartes postales votre nom votre
numéro de téléphone et l'indicatif de
votre département à et maintenant jouant
cedex 15 175 300 paris brûle mais cela
dit je crois bien que garcimore tentent
d'entrer désespérément depuis quelques
instants
mais il nous nous interrompre parce
qu'il est certain que des millions de
centimes ça intimide fait un timide tout
oui bonjour vous avez pas vu alors
absolument ya longtemps que mag est pas
encore les gars vous n'aviez pas joué le
tour mais j'aimerais bien avant que mon
juillet à que nous raconter un petit peu
comment s'est passé ce voyage en italie
des années à venir
dites moi il était d'abord noailles et à
rome mais quand même il se doit puisque
j'avais donné beaucoup parlé de venise
je suis allé tout décontracté en voiture
bien et quand je suis arrivé là-bas il y
avait des chances parce qu'il promet il
y avait un orage
il ya beaucoup d'eau qu'ils tombent
alors c'est grave parce que trop démunis
bon il peut mais quand j'ai vu tout le
monde embarque j'avais cru qu avait
décidé de siéger appelle un taxi
taquilla une barre qui est venue alors
il y avait passé l'été ici peut-être des
carabinieri la police ils sont pas trop
forts la protection civile le drôme
meilleur gagne vous l'êtes a fait mener
en bateau en gondole cobras ont apprécié
les visites du passé une semaine avant
de visiter les pyramides ils
raconteraient quelqu'un qui m'a en fait
c'est pas une petite sacra conseil
m'expliquer et tous les
mon mille et unes tous anciens alors
comment expliquer ça je vous l'expliqué
je vais écouter
alors on prend jamais beaucoup alors il
m'avait dit que 4000 ans avant
jésus-christ 5000 ans quand quelqu'un
aurait il fait un boom un ado après le
metteur en scène sera offert et comme sa
fille un sou pour ça que ça soit là qui
m'ont mis ya rien oui là c'est le petit
moment alors il m'avait dit que ces gens
là c'était populaire comme on y croyait
que la vraie vie ça commençait à près
d'un mois qui serait ambitieux pena qui
s'interdit arrive c'est du régime alors
les yeux qui morace était tellement
léger qui flottait dans l'air et tous
il y avait pourtant il flotte tous
pousse-pousse où une mosquée est
candidat vit encore quelque chose lâche
on impose comme sauter haut nous tous et
pour tous bords et il m'avait dit ça ce
qui m'avait si je vous ai pas dit c'est
quoi ce qui m'a fait vraiment rigoler
c'est qu'après il m'a dit bon au bout de
quelques temps la famille allait voir si
le mondial est bien qu'on est allé au
bout de quelques temps alors ils les
maquillent qu'on arrive à le mans malgré
qu'ils étaient embaumés tout ne serait
plus un puisqu'il avait disparu alors
c'est pas parce qu'on est un bon mec
saluons moment que nous paraît comme un
méfait avant d'évoquer temps il me
l'avez vous fait un tour qui m'a studio
parce que des fois il ya des taux qui
masque des taux qui massent pas maîtrisé
vous faire un nom sait y faire dans
l'enceinte oki masse tout nouveau
charlevoix cinéma me semble à vrai dire
qu'il a bien marché mais ça me réveille
à fait les taux des robinets non non non
ça c'en est trop pour vous savez tous
les gobelets c'est une toque immense
tour nous savons tous qu'il m'a studio à
écouter vraiment jeudi regard sinon on
vous fait un retour en force et un
aujourd'hui pour des mots
c'est à dire qu'il se dirige vers pierre
lannes ont très nettement
bien il va prendre son temps
non non on va le laisser pendant 30 ans
toute façon nous sommes là jusqu'à 18
heures non mais voilà ne m'a pas appelé
c'est pas terminé il on regarde d'autres
le corner bien vous surveiller tous à
des nuances aux jeunes alors maintenant
c'est en compagnie de garcimore que je
vous laisse je vous retrouve dans une de
mieux bon voilà il ya jérémy les bba
tactique attaques qui sont tout content
de le retrouver
il ya le voyez souvent y ait multiplié
les cartes fini les pièces tout ça mais
disait même une plaie les avait fait la
multiplication du lait c'est à dire y
avait bien un petit verre j'arrive il a
un éveil adulé mais cela il est plus
grand que l'autre alors avec les petits
doivent essayer de remplir des grands il
est plein un homme c'est pas fini c'est
vrai maintenant avec ceux ci
j'ai essayé de rempli lot parce que
l'autre s'il est encore plus grand ça
doit être content elle est bien remplie
se remplit ceci il essayait encore de
rempli l'autre qui les plus grandes
salles et voient remettre là
ah oui il est bien remplie au dollar
cela avait rempli les tout grands tours
henry gimenez officiel c'est peut-être
ça vous ça passe ou plus puisque vous
pensez vont peut-être un petit truc dans
le vert fils est ce que vous pensez
mais pour montrer que ces passages que
vous passez maintenant un celle ci est
rempli tous les quatre parce qu'avant il
y en avait qu'une remplie maintenant ils
vont se retrouver a rempli tous les
quatre alors s'il vous plaît vous
regarde bien on va voir on prend le
premier depuis mai il est rempli les
deuxièmes ça va comme ça comme ça sent
bon les troisièmes sais pas s'il va
essayer parce que ça ça et voilà les
quatre voies 6 et rampling et il reste
encore on aurait tout petit peu l'alluré
un peu mes partenaires c'est très facile
et mais il faut le faire
[Musique]